So now we have this wonderful straight
forward equation for the amount of money
that Grant's friends are going to pay him
once they buy their glasses, wiper, and
their spray nozzles. However just when we
think we're starting to figure things out
for him situation gets a little bit more
complicated. Even though this means more
work for us, this is great for Grant,
because more of his friends have asked if
they can buy his products. The day after
his first round of requests came in, even
more of his friends and his friend's
friends heard about his new incredible
inventions, and asked him to add to them,
to the list of people to buy his products.
51 more people requested glasses wipers,
and 25 more people wanted to buy 2 spray
nozzles each. This equation no longer
tells us the total amount of money that
Grant's going to earn from his friends,
and his friend's friends buying his wipers
and nozzles. So, what we need to do is
create a new equation. We need to come up
with a different way to express a that
takes into account this new information
that we have, but also doesn't forget what
we had before.